this is a new interpretation of Dracula
nobody's seen before for me I feel very
lucky to be able to show Dracula in imax
very few films have that opportunity to
be able to see this tale of how one man
devised an entire empire and so's the
seeds of his own destruction wise to
this iconic figure I can't think of any
other way I would like people to see
this than you know the full immersive
imax experience you're talking about
real history going back to find out what
is the source of this story how was this
never been done before you the ultimate
superhero bata begin with and I feel
very satisfied that you know fans of the
material would enjoy the spectacle I
must have seen the film 100 times now
put on smaller screens and without the
sand without did the ameri sickness I
was able to watch it for the first time
I'm feel like I was really there with
blood no I max I'm so beautiful it's the
Irish landscape that I had grown up
amongst I was looking at a things just
popped is an elegance that we fought
really hard to have in this film and
deserve to the muscularity make certain
elegance it's the storytelling that
should take it to the experiencing
fortunately right now we have the medium
to be able to not only tell that story
but telling on a grand scale I'm very
grateful for the experience of having
been able to watch this on amex it was
invigorating to see all of the work that
we are doing finally really comforted
it's going to surprise a lot of people
I've been spoiled now I can't see how
I'm going to be able to make films after
this without a consistent of being imax